The tumultuous arrest of women's rights activist
Emmeline Pankhurst outside Buckingham Palace
- and Emily Davison throwing herself
in front of the horses at the Kings Derby -
iconic Images from 1913.
The struggle for womens suffrage in Europe is just heating up. In Germany activists like Helene Lange and
Clara Zetkin were a driving force to get the
vote - in a country where a women were banned
from even attending political gatherings until
1908.
From 1914 external factors shaped the role
of women in society.
Many say that women's contribution to the
war effort back home helped secure them the
vote in 1918 in Britain...
And in Germany.
After the revolution - women thronged to the
streets to vote for the first time in elections
to the Weimar National Assembly in January
1919.
Latecomers to the table of womens' suffrage
were Spain in 1931, France in 1944 and Italy
in 1945.
And in Portugal women were barred from voting
in national politics until as recently as
1976...
And although it's not uncommon to see women
at the helm in European politics today...
take a wider view - and you'll see the struggle
for total equality is stilll far from over.